Everybody who's taking the oath, stand up.
所有宣誓的人，请起立。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共电台的《美国生活》节目。
And everybody speak up now, so we can hear your voice. I--
现在大家大声说出来，让我们能听见你们的声音。我——
I--
我——
Hereby declare on oath--
在此郑重宣誓——
That I absolutely and entirely--
我将绝对并完全地——
I absolutely and entirely--
我绝对并完全地——
Renounce and abjure--
放弃并断绝——
All allegiance and fidelity--
所有的效忠和忠诚——
To any foreign prince--
对任何外国君主——
Potentate--
统治者——
State or sovereignty.
国家或主权。
That I will support and defend--
我将支持并捍卫——
The constitution--
宪法——
Monday. US District Court in Chicago. The honorable Abraham Lincoln Marovitz presiding. 30 men women standing, taking the oath to become citizens. What would you say to somebody becoming a citizen of this country?
周一。芝加哥美国地方法院。由尊敬的亚伯拉罕·林肯·马洛维茨法官主持。30名男女站立着，进行入籍宣誓。你会对一个即将成为这个国家公民的人说些什么？
So help me God.
愿上帝保佑我。
Now shake hands with your neighbor on each side and congratulate yourself. Lets give a nice hand, folks.
现在，和身边的邻居握手，向自己祝贺。大家鼓个掌吧。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Sit down for a minute, now we can gab a little bit. There's not much a judge can do that pleases everybody, but this pleases me. And I'm particularly pleased to do this, because my pa and ma were immigrants, and my father's proudest possession was his citizenship papers. And the first few years at election time I suggest who he might vote for, he said don't tell me how to vote, I'm a citizen like you.
坐下一会儿吧，现在我们可以聊聊了。法官能做的事不多，很难让每个人都满意，但这事让我很高兴。我尤其高兴做这件事，因为我的父母也是移民，我父亲最引以为傲的财产就是他的公民身份文件。最初几年，每到选举时，我建议他投谁的票，他说“别告诉我怎么投票，我和你一样是公民”。
Judge Marovitz is 93 years old. He still runs a citizenship ceremony only because he loves it. He's been part of the Chicago political scene going back to the bad old days of the original Daley machine four decades ago. His office is lined with signed photos of politicians of that era and luminaries. Jimmy Durante, Frank Sinatra, Bob Hope.
马洛维茨法官今年93岁了。他依然坚持主持入籍仪式，纯粹是因为他热爱这项工作。四十年来的芝加哥政坛，从最初戴利机器时代的黑暗岁月至今，他一直身在其中。他的办公室里挂满了那个时代政客和名流的亲笔签名照。吉米·杜兰特、弗兰克·辛纳屈、鲍勃·霍普。
But there is something about welcoming people into this country that somehow conjures a picture of life here, evokes a picture of life here that is rosier than, for example, the grimy world of Chicago politics. It is as if, when welcoming people into this nation, we tell them not about the competitive, harsh realities of life here sometimes. Not the country we see around us every single day. But the country we want to believe this is.
但欢迎人们来到这个国家，似乎能勾勒出一幅关于这里生活的美好图景，比芝加哥政治的污浊世界要美好得多。就好像在欢迎人们加入这个国家时，我们不告诉他们这里有时竞争激烈、残酷的现实。不告诉他们我们每天亲眼所见的国家。而是告诉他们我们希望这个国家成为的样子。
Every once in a while I'm introduced as a self-made man. And at 93, I've yet to meet one.  Or a self-made lady. I've had help all my life. A little push from some, a big push from others. But a kind word from everybody. Reach out to help people. Do a little good deed every day. Regardless of their color, regardless of their religion. And don't judge anybody by the color of their skin or the church they go to. But reach out every day. Don't let a day go by.
偶尔有人介绍我为“白手起家的人”。但93岁了，我还没见过一个真正完全白手起家的人。或者白手起家的女性。我一生都得到过帮助。一些人推了我一把，另一些人推了一大把。但每个人都给了我一句友善的话。去帮助别人吧。每天做一点好事。不管他们的肤色如何，不管他们的宗教信仰如何。不要以肤色或他们去的教堂来评判任何人。但每天都要伸出援手。别让日子白白溜走。
His citizenship ceremony is so moving that immigration officials, whose job is normally to enforce all the laws that make it hard for people to become Americans, immigration officials compete to be assigned to the naturalization ceremony. It's coveted. And they're only allowed to stay on the job for a limited time.  A few months.
他的入籍仪式非常感人，以至于移民局官员——他们的工作通常是执行那些限制人们成为美国人的严苛法律——都竞相争取参加入籍仪式的机会。这非常抢手。他们只能担任这份工作有限的一段时间。几个月而已。
I'm Ira Glass. Each week on this radio program, we choose some topic. Bring you a variety of stories on that topic. Today's program, Welcome to America. Stories of people arriving here, how they see us, how we think they should see us, and what they know about us that we don't necessarily know about ourselves.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。这个广播节目每周会选择一个主题。为大家带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是“欢迎来到美国”。讲述人们来到这里的故事，他们如何看待我们，他们认为我们应该如何看待他们，以及他们知道哪些我们未必了解的关于我们自己的事情。
Act One, What do Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sigmund Freud have in common? A true story of a group of Austrians who come to New York City to teach in the public high schools, and how their experience here is nothing like what Americans seem to think it will be.
第一幕，阿诺·施瓦辛格和西格蒙德·弗洛伊德有什么共同点？讲述一群奥地利人来到纽约市公立高中任教的真实故事，以及他们在这一段经历与美国人预想的完全不同。
Act Two, Are Movies Stronger than Communism? A man flees Cuba, comes to America, always partly regrets it. His son embarks on a project to convince him that he did the right thing. Stay with us.
第二幕，电影的力量比共产主义更强大吗？一个男人逃离古巴，来到美国，内心却始终带有一丝悔意。他的儿子发起了一个项目，试图让他相信他做出了正确的决定。请留步。
Act One. What do Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sigmund Freud Have In Common?
第一幕。阿诺·施瓦辛格和西格蒙德·弗洛伊德有什么共同点？
Well, the New York City public schools consist of roughly 65,000 teachers, 1.1 million students. And the New York City public schools could not find enough math and science teachers for its classrooms. There's a shortage. Americans somehow do not want these jobs.
纽约市公立学校大约有6.5万名教师和110万名学生。但纽约公立学校却无法为教室找到足够的数学和科学教师。出现了短缺。美国人不知为何不想做这些工作。
Meanwhile, in the European nation of Austria, there was a surplus of math and science teachers. Somebody noticed these two facts. One thing led to another. And before long, there was a decision to import Austrian teachers to New York City. This summer, school officials began the hiring process with job interviews that they conducted by videoconferencing between City College in Harlem and Vienna. Writer David Rakoff has this account of the Austrians' welcome to America and of the platitudes about this country that people kept trying to force upon them.
与此同时，在欧洲的奥地利，数学和科学教师却有过剩。有人注意到了这两个事实。一件事促成了另一件事。没过多久，就决定引进奥地利教师来纽约市。今年夏天，校方通过在哈林区的城市学院与维也纳之间进行视频会议来面试，开始了招聘程序。作家大卫·拉科夫报道了奥地利人受到的欢迎，以及人们不断试图强加给他们的关于这个国家的陈词滥调。
Any job interview is an awkward affair. Any job interview with a panel of five interviewers, even more so. How about a job interview with a panel of five interviewers, conducted in a foreign language, via transatlantic live video teleconferencing, complete with an echo and an audio delay with reporters from Nightline , the local TV news, and New York's major dailies watching?
任何工作面试都是一件令人尴尬的事情。由五名面试官组成的小组进行的面试更是如此。那么，如果是由五名面试官组成的小组，用外语，通过跨大西洋现场视频会议，还伴有回声和音频延迟，且由《夜线》节目、当地电视新闻和纽约各大日报的记者观看，这种面试又会怎样呢？
Two young men busily tape up a purple City College banner with packing tape for the news cameras' benefit. Everyone is nervous. Questions are repeated, slowed down. It all makes for very halting progress. A typical question. "Would you please tell us why you have decided to become a teacher?" Typical answer. [IN AUSTRIAN ACCENT] "Sorry. It's very hard to hear. I didn't understand you. Could you please ask again the question, please?"
两名年轻人忙着为新闻摄影机用包装胶带贴起一面紫色的城市学院横幅。每个人都很紧张。问题被重复，语速被放慢。这使得过程非常缓慢。一个典型问题：“请告诉我们你为什么决定成为一名老师？”典型回答：[带有奥地利口音]“抱歉。听不太清楚。我没听懂。请您再问一遍好吗？”
How much of an actual cultural gap is there between the two sides? Well, when asked what knowledge they had have of New York Schools, one woman answered that she heard, quote, "The kids were having guns and using drugs." But she doesn't seem overly concerned.
双方之间到底存在多大的文化鸿沟？当被问及对纽约学校有什么了解时，一位女士回答说，她听说“孩子们都有枪，还在吸毒”。但她似乎并不特别担心。
It becomes clear that the Austrian teachers are hoping to come to New York out of a sense of adventure, to experience another culture firsthand, and to improve their English, although for the most part, they speak quite well. One fellow hungers for New York's multiethnic society. "I want to see the blacks. Where I am from, there is only one black people a year," is how he puts it. "Oh," one of the African-American principals whispers. "Vermont."
显而易见，奥地利教师希望来到纽约是出于冒险感，为了亲身经历另一种文化，并提高英语水平，尽管他们大多数人的英语说得很好。其中一个人渴望纽约的多种族社会。“我想见见黑人。我住的地方，一年可能也就见到一个黑人，”他是这样说的。“噢，”一位非裔美国校长轻声说，“那是佛蒙特州。”
Three of the men, when asked why they became teachers, innocently and unabashedly answered, "because I love children." I don't know that an American male would answer that question in that way, even if it were true.
当被问及为何成为教师时，其中三名男子天真且毫无掩饰地回答说：“因为我爱孩子。”我不知道美国男性即使是真心的，是否会这样回答问题。
The final question has them all completely stymied. "Can you tell us anything else about yourself that should make us want to select you as one of our teachers?" Answering this kind of question is an acquired skill, even for Americans. You remember how it took at least three job interviews before you learned that maintaining unwavering eye contact and being hypomanically gung ho weren't just weird and arrogant. They were required. For the Austrians, trained in a kind of courtly European reserve, being asked to assert their sterling qualities in full voice seems truly baffling-- a trick question straight out of Alice in Wonderland .
最后一个问题让他们全都彻底困惑了。“你能告诉我们关于你自己的其他什么事，让我们想要选择你作为我们的老师吗？”回答这类问题是一种后天习得的技能，即便对美国人来说也是如此。你还记得至少经过三次面试后，你才学会了保持坚定不移的眼神接触并表现得亢奋热情，这并不是怪异和傲慢。这是必须的。对于受过欧洲那种彬彬有礼的克制训练的奥地利人来说，被要求大声断言自己出色的品质简直让人费解——这就像是《爱丽丝梦游仙境》里的陷阱题。
The best answer comes from the undisputed star of the day, Andrea Unger. With her doctorate in Genetics at age 28, perfect English, and blonde movie star beauty, she has all of us-- educators and reporters alike-- immediately am profoundly enslaved. This being a high school world that I have entered on this day, I am hyper-attuned to adolescent paradigms, and she seems to be that rarest of legendary creatures in high school pantheon-- the popular girl, beloved by students and faculty alike, who, in addition to being pretty and smart, is also nice.
最好的回答来自当天无可争议的明星，安德里亚·昂格。她28岁就拥有遗传学博士学位，英语完美，长得像金发电影明星，让我们所有人都——无论是教育工作者还是记者——立刻被深深迷住了。这毕竟是我今天进入的高中世界，我对青少年范式非常敏感，而她似乎是高中万神殿里那种极其罕见的传奇生物——那个既漂亮又聪明，而且心地善良，深受学生和教职员工喜爱的人气女孩。
She's addressed as Dr. Unger. Scarcely four minutes into her interview, the borough superintendents are mouthing, "I want her," out of camera range. When asked her final, "Tell us why you're the best" question, she answers, "I don't know if I'm the very best, but I will do my best. And if that's not enough, I will do much better." We would follow her into the very mouth of hell, singing songs all the while. "See you in September," says one of the interviewers after she has left the room in Vienna.
人们称她为昂格博士。在面试仅进行了四分钟后，区监督员就在镜头外动着嘴唇说：“我要她。”当被问及最后一个“告诉我们为什么你是最棒的”问题时，她回答说：“我不知道我是否是最棒的，但我会尽我所能。如果这还不够，我会做得更好。”只要她还在唱歌，我们甚至愿意跟随她走进地狱。维也纳那边的面试官在她离开房间后说：“九月见。”
Let's play a word association game. One. Austrian teacher. Association-- that extraordinary opening shot. A camera impossibly placed in the Alpine ether, coming in ever closer to the mountaintop to finally focus and settle on the turning figure, her arms outstretched, face beaming, overwhelmed with joy and music, the young novitiate, Fraulein Maria.
我们来玩个联想游戏。一。奥地利老师。联想——那非凡的开场镜头。摄像机在阿尔卑斯山的虚空处放置，不断靠近山顶，最后聚焦并锁定在那个旋转的身影上，她张开双臂，脸庞闪耀着光芒，沉浸在欢乐和音乐中，那是年轻的见习修女，玛利亚。
[MUSIC - "THE SOUND OF MUSIC" BY JULIE ANDREWS]
[音乐 - 朱莉·安德鲁斯演唱的《音乐之声》]
The Sound of Music. Maria von Trapp. Julie Andrews. As seen on television so many times that anyone can complete the following sentence-- "How do you solve a problem like--?"
《音乐之声》。玛利亚·冯·特拉普。朱莉·安德鲁斯。电视上播放过太多次，以至于任何人都能接上下面这句话——“怎么解决像……这样的问题？”
Two. New York City public schools. Association. Metal detectors, baggy jeans, box cutters, white flight. A futile, underfunded, ineffectual exercise in neglect. The last stop before entering the revolving door prison system.
二。纽约市公立学校。联想。金属探测器、肥大牛仔裤、美工刀、白人外逃。一场徒劳、资金不足、无效且被忽视的训练。进入监狱循环系统前的最后一站。
In part, it is these exact stereotypes, the guileless, defenseless foreigners being used for target practice by young toughs, that have so piqued the interest of the national media. And it is these very stereotypes that I will find debunked time and again over the next five months.
某种程度上，正是这些刻板印象，即纯朴无防备的外国人被年轻暴徒当作打靶练习的对象，才激发了全国媒体的兴趣。而正是这些刻板印象，在接下来的五个月里我将一次又一次地证明它们是错误的。
The reporter from ABC asks all the questions that are on the minds of those of us not in public education. They are, verbatim, "New York is one of the toughest places to teach in this country. Are you up for challenge?" "New York is a very diverse city, and there are students from various different countries, and almost anywhere you teach, you'll find students of various backgrounds, various ethnicities. Is that going to be very different for you?" "You, no doubt, have heard about a string of rather unfortunate incidents we've had in the past school year. Students shooting other students in school. Are you aware of that, and did that at all affect your decision to do this?"
来自ABC的记者问了所有那些不在公共教育界的人心中想问的问题。它们原文如下：“纽约是这个国家最难教学的地方之一。你准备好迎接挑战了吗？”“纽约是一个多元化的城市，有来自不同国家的学生，几乎无论你在哪里教书，都会发现背景和种族各异的学生。这对你来说会有很大不同吗？”“你无疑听说过过去学年发生的一系列不幸事件。学生在学校枪杀其他学生。你了解这一点吗，这是否影响了你做这项决定的决心？”
All of this takes place at City College, where, for generations, immigrants made their start in this country. And all of this takes place in New York, a city which had not one of the much-publicized school shooting sprees of the past year.
所有这一切都发生在城市学院，几代移民都在这里开启了他们在该国的生活。所有这一切都发生在纽约，一个在过去一年中没有发生过任何广受宣传的校园枪击案的城市。
The posters in California Lounge at the Delta terminal of Kennedy airport are, paradoxically, of London, Paris, and Amsterdam. Perhaps the only thing that seems authentically California to me about the California Lounge is how boring it is. I and 13 other newspeople wait for the Austrians get through customs.
肯尼迪机场达美航空候机室加州休息区的海报，讽刺的是，贴的是伦敦、巴黎和阿姆斯特丹。也许加州休息区唯一让我觉得真实的地方就是它有多么无聊。我和其他13名新闻工作者等待奥地利人通过海关。
The teachers' union has issued this deadpan statement. Quote, "We're pleased they're here, but it's regrettable that New York doesn't pay its teachers more." Unquote. The starting salary for a teacher in New York City's $29,600, which is a living wage in this town, but not fat city, by any means.
教师工会发表了一份毫无表情的声明。引用：“我们很高兴他们来到这里，但遗憾的是纽约没有给老师更高的薪水。”引用结束。纽约市教师的起薪是29,600美元，在这个城市只能说是维持生计，绝非富足之地。
Those same two young men from City College come in with that same purple banner, and try to tape it up on the wall, to no avail. When eventually the teachers arrive, my heart races a bit, as if I were in the presence of major celebrities. This is especially true when I see Andrea.
来自城市学院的那两名年轻人拿着同样的紫色横幅进来，试图把它贴在墙上，但无济于事。当奥地利老师们最终到达时，我的心跳稍微加快了一些，仿佛我正处在超级明星的面前。当我看到安德里亚时，这种感觉尤为强烈。
I'm also shocked by how young they all look. They're all in their twenties. This only increases by fear for them. Just listen to the poker-faced reporter.
我也对他们看起来都如此年轻感到震惊。他们都才二十出头。这只会增加我为他们感到的恐惧。听听那面无表情的记者。
My name is Andrea Unger.
我叫安德里亚·昂格。
How do you feel to be here?
你感觉如何？
Oh, it's absolutely great. And I'm absolutely overwhelmed by the interest of the press and by the friendliness of the people.
噢，这绝对太棒了。我被媒体的关注和人们的友善深深打动了。
Where will you be teaching?
你将在哪里任教？
I will be teaching in Brooklyn, at the Franklin D. Roosevelt High School.
我将在布鲁克林的富兰克林·D·罗斯福高中任教。
I see.
我明白了。
This is a nice one?
这是一所好学校吗？
You know, I was just talking to Joyce Koppen about it. It's got 4,000 kids. Which is extraordinary. I think the Franklin Roosevelt High School is going to be, um, a completely interesting experience for you.
你知道，我刚和乔伊斯·科彭谈过。它有4000名学生。这太了不起了。我认为富兰克林·罗斯福高中对你来说将是一次非常有趣的经历。
Whatever it means, eh?
不管那意味着什么，对吧？
Andrea and three other of the 26 Austrian teachers, Lutz Holzinger, Elke Rogl, and Nikolaus Ettel are all assigned to teach at FDR. I decide to follow them. Here's Nikki.
安德里亚和其他三名奥地利教师（共26名）——卢茨·霍尔津格、埃尔克·罗格尔和尼古拉斯·埃特尔都被分配到了FDR高中。我决定跟着他们。这是尼基。
My name is Nikolaus Ettel.
我叫尼古拉斯·埃特尔。
And where will you be teaching?
你将在哪里任教？
I will be teaching mathematics.
我将教数学。
Where?
在哪里？
In Brooklyn, FDR High School.
在布鲁克林的FDR高中。
So you're one of the four Brooklyn--
所以你是布鲁克林的四名老师之一——
Yeah.
是的。
And do you have any thoughts about what it is you're about to embark on?
对于你即将开启的旅程，你有什么想法吗？
I want to just look what happens. I know about the school. I've heard that it's a big school.
我只想看看会发生什么。我了解那所学校。我听说那是一所很大的学校。
It's huge. It's 4,000 kids. I just found that out.
非常大。有4000个孩子。我刚刚才知道。
This is one of our customs as New Yorkers, welcoming foreigners to our shores. Because we are so often frightened by living here, we are annoyed and offended when visitors fail to show the proper signs of terror. So we try to scare the living daylights out of them. And if oblique auguries of physical peril don't work, well then, we can always talk about rent.
这是我们作为纽约人的习俗之一，欢迎外国人来到我们的海岸。因为我们生活在这里常常感到恐惧，所以当访客没有表现出应有的恐惧迹象时，我们会感到恼火和冒犯。所以我们试图把他们吓个半死。如果暗示身体危险没用，嗯，我们总能谈谈房租。
I want to live together with some Brooklyn teachers. Because low costs.
我想和一些布鲁克林的老师住在一起。因为成本低。
Yeah.  It's a particularly expensive time in New York City right now. Rents are kind of-- well, you never know.
是的。纽约市现在物价特别高。房租有点——嗯，你永远不知道。
Luckily enough for the Austrian teachers, their introduction to life in New York City and its public school system will not be left up to the paranoid, hysterical likes of me and other members of the fourth estate. Like the news cameraman who, upon hearing that they will be teaching high school, whistles, asking no one in particular, "Anybody know karate?"
幸运的是，奥地利老师对纽约生活和公立学校系统的了解，不会被像我这样偏执、歇斯底里的第四权力成员所左右。就像那位摄影师，当听说他们要去教高中时，吹了声口哨，问有没有人知道空手道。
They will instead sit through a series of days-long orientation sessions at the Board of Ed, where they will be turned into fully functional New Yorkers with social security numbers and bank accounts. The bank accounts courtesy of Miss Licorice, her actual name, the representative from the Chase Manhattan bank. They are taught how to write checks.
相反，他们将参加教育部为期数天的指导课程，在那里他们将变身为拥有社会保障号码和银行账户的成熟纽约人。银行账户多亏了利科里斯小姐（她的真名），来自大通曼哈顿银行的代表。他们被教导如何写支票。
Don't they have checks in Austria?
奥地利没有支票吗？
Of course they do. That's different, I guess.
当然有。不过我想那不一样。
At these sessions, they're told that the United States is a free country. They're told that they don't have to register with the police wherever they live. They're told that when they apply for a driver's license, they won't actually have to know how to fix an engine, as they do in Austria. They're told that in New York, teachers use modern teaching methods, unlike, it is implied, Austria.
在这些会议上，他们被告知美国是一个自由国家。他们被告知无论住在哪里，都不必向警方登记。他们被告知申请驾照时，实际上不需要像在奥地利那样知道怎么修理引擎。他们被告知在纽约，老师使用现代教学方法，暗示这与奥地利不同。
The New York educators warn them time and again about the dangers of the dreaded "chalk and talk," that driest, most outmoded Teutonic kind of pedagogy where one stands at the chalkboard, lectures, maybe draws some diagrams, but has no capacity to field inquiry or lead a discussion. The underlying message is, Toto, you're not in Klagenfurt anymore.
纽约的教育者一次又一次地警告他们关于“粉笔和讲课”的危险，那种最干燥、最过时的条顿式教学法，即一个人站在黑板前，念讲稿，也许画些图表，但没有能力提出疑问或引导讨论。潜在的信息是，托托，你已经不在克拉根福了。
You seem like a lot of that chalk and talk is what you're accustomed to. I like to talk to my people about hitting the ground running, like they do in the war. That's what you do. You're in there very quickly. If you walk the walk and talk the talk, kids will respect you. What I mean by that is, establish yourself as the leader in this situation immediately, and you will survive.
你们似乎习惯了那种粉笔加讲课。我喜欢和同事们谈论要像在战场上一样迅速投入工作。这就是你们要做的。很快就会进入状态。如果你言行一致，孩子们就会尊重你。我的意思是，立即确立你在这种环境下的领导地位，你就能生存下来。
One of the more useful moments in the whole orientation, and one that reminds them why they are here, comes when the Austrians meet actual New York City high school kids for the first time.
当奥地利人第一次见到真正的纽约市高中生时，整个指导期中一个非常有用的时刻出现了，它提醒了他们为什么要来到这里。
This communication is very essential to the learning process between you and the students. The following, which are being passed out, a word that you will hear us use to address our peers and to address some of the teachers also.
这种交流对于你和学生之间的学习过程至关重要。接下来发给你们的，是一个你们会听到我们用来称呼同龄人以及老师的词。
What we will be teaching you is our language.
我们要教给你们的是我们的语言。
They run for their flash cards. "Bounce," "whatever's clever," "the bomb," "jiggy," "phat," "you buggin'," "you played yourself." The lesson in slang continues just a few days later in a week the class about life in the city that is being called New York 101 by the media. Although no one out of the media seems to have another name for it. They just call it "what the media are calling New York 101."
他们开始研究卡片。“Bounce”、“whatever's clever”、“the bomb”、“jiggy”、“phat”、“you buggin'”、“you played yourself”。这种俚语课程在几天后的“纽约101”课程（媒体给生活在城市的课程起的名）中继续。虽然媒体之外似乎没人这么叫。他们只是管这叫“媒体所谓的纽约101”。
The professor, a retired English scholar and native Brooklynite, spends the first 20 minutes of the first class quizzing them on their various subway routes and telling them quicker alternatives. It is one New Yorkers' favorite pastimes, telling one another the best subway routes to get someplace. As the other New Yorker in the room, I am fascinated, and cannot resist even chiming in at one point about the long underground transfer between the 4/5 and the 2/3 at Fulton Street. The Austrians stare blankly and seem exhausted.
教授是一位退休的英语学者和土生土长的布鲁克林人，他花了第一节课的前20分钟测试他们的各种地铁路线，并告诉他们更快捷的替代方案。这是纽约人最喜欢的消遣之一，互相告诉对方去某个地方的最佳地铁路线。作为房间里的另一个纽约人，我很着迷，甚至忍不住在某个时刻插话，提到富尔顿街4/5号线和2/3号线之间长长的地下换乘通道。奥地利人面无表情，显得筋疲力尽。
Then comes colloquialisms lessons in the form of a handout. This glossary of New York argot has words and phrases like "86," "schmear," "bimbo," "maven," "what am I, chopped liver?" and "schlepping all over town, looking for some tchochkes." All of which would be very useful, if it were 1949, if you were a hard-boiled cutie pie gun moll, or in the USO, or a been-around-the-block dishwater blonde waitress, or a private dick, anyone from a Damon Runyon story, or auditioning for Seinfeld.
然后是通过讲义进行的口语教学。这份纽约俚语词汇表包含了像“86”、“schmear”、“bimbo”、“maven”、“what am I, chopped liver?”以及“schlepping all over town, looking for some tchochkes”这样的词汇和短语。如果是在1949年，如果你是一个硬汉式的时髦女郎，或者在劳军联合组织里，或者一个在江湖打滚的洗碗女服务员，或者一个私家侦探，任何达蒙·鲁尼恩故事里的人，或者是为《宋飞传》试镜，这些都会非常有用。
What becomes evident over the course of the orientation is that the Austrians are also being given an unvarnished glimpse, albeit an unwitting one, into what it is truly like to be a student in a public high school in North America. Hours spent sitting, listening to lecture after lecture, frequently droning, and frequently about things they will never need to know. The bureaucratic structure of the board of education, for example. Or how to say "86 of whiskey, down with the schmear!"
在指导过程中显而易见的是，奥地利人也得到了一个毫无修饰的、尽管是无意的一瞥，看到了成为北美公立高中学生真正是什么感觉。时间花在坐着，听一个又一个讲座，经常嗡嗡作响，而且经常是关于他们永远不需要知道的事情。例如教育部的官僚结构。或者如何说“86杯威士忌，加上涂抹酱！”
The orientation does teach them how to find an apartment in New York City-- no laughing matter. Well, if it's a laughing matter, it's in that bitter, rueful kind of way. But very surprisingly, in one weekend of hitting the streets during a Wall Street boom, they all have homes. Homes they have given names to.
指导确实教了他们如何在纽约市找公寓——这可不是开玩笑的事。好吧，如果这是一件可笑的事，那也是那种苦涩、悔恨的方式。但非常令人惊讶的是，在华尔街繁荣时期的一个周末走访街头后，他们都有了住所。他们还给住所起了名字。
This is Little Austria. Can't take your call now. Please leave a message after the long beep. Thank you.
这里是小奥地利。现在无法接听您的电话。请在长哔声后留言。谢谢。
Hi. This is the girls' apartment. We're not hear now. Please leave a message. We will call you back. Bye bye.
嗨。这是女孩们的公寓。我们现在不在。请留言。我们会给您回电。再见。
Elke and Andrea live in the Gravesend section of Brooklyn. Lutz and Nikolaus are in Sunset Park, another part of Brooklyn. Their place is huge and sunny. Seven of the teachers occupy two apartments in the same building. They take me along with them when they go to see their school for the first time a few days before the beginning of the semester. It's two subway rides away, in the Bensonhurst neighborhood of Brooklyn.
埃尔克和安德里亚住在布鲁克林的格雷夫森德区。卢茨和尼古拉斯在布鲁克林的日落公园。他们的地方很大而且阳光充足。七名老师住进同一栋楼的两间公寓。学期开始前几天，当他们第一次去学校看的时候，我跟着他们一起去了。离那儿要坐两趟地铁，在布鲁克林的本森赫斯特社区。
Bensonhurst was the scene of some racist violence a few years back. I am quite frankly terrified at the thought of going there. As far as I knew, if you weren't white, Italian-American and straight, you stayed out of Bensonhurst. But as it turns out, FDR's 4,000 kids are from 72 different countries, representing 32 different language groups. One third of them identified as limited English-speaking youngsters, meaning they entered the US within the last two or three years. Easily 60% of the entire student body was born outside the United States. The Austrians will be right at home.
本森赫斯特几年前曾发生过种族暴力事件。坦率地说，想到要去那里我就很害怕。据我所知，如果你不是白人、意大利裔美国人且是异性恋，你就远离本森赫斯特。但事实证明，FDR的4000个孩子来自72个不同的国家，代表了32个不同的语言群体。三分之一的人被认定为英语水平有限的青少年，意味着他们在过去两三年内来到美国。整个学生群体中至少有60%出生在美国境外。奥地利人会感到宾至如归。
The media attention surrounding them shows no signs of abating. Their schools are Fielding inquiries from CBS, Austrian TV, and a Japanese television crew. The Austrians tell me how fed up they're getting with being portrayed as being too scared to take the subway, unfamiliar with different ethnicities, and oblivious to social problems. Lutz gently points out that the small matter of the genocidal civil war in former Yugoslavia is happening not too far from Vienna. There are refugees coming into Austria every day. Lutz and Nikki are not men who are unaware of the outside world. "We are international people," says Nikki, whose girlfriend is spending the year working in Moscow.
围绕他们的媒体关注没有任何减弱的迹象。学校正在应付哥伦比亚广播公司、奥地利电视台和日本电视摄制组的询问。奥地利人告诉我，他们对被描绘成不敢坐地铁、不熟悉不同种族、对社会问题一无所知感到厌烦。卢茨温和地指出，前南斯拉夫种族灭绝内战这一小事，离维也纳并不远。每天都有难民涌入奥地利。卢茨和尼基不是对外面的世界一无所知的人。“我们是国际化的人，”尼基说，他的女友这一年正在莫斯科工作。
I ask them if they have drugs and teenage pregnancy in Vienna. Lutz replies, of course, although not to the extent of New York City, obviously. But it's really an idiotic question. Where do I think they come from, Shangri-La?
我问他们维也纳有没有毒品和少女怀孕现象。卢茨回答说，当然有，虽然显然没纽约市那么严重。但这真是一个愚蠢的问题。他以为我以为他们来自哪里，香格里拉吗？
Franklin Delano Roosevelt High is beside a huge cemetery. Literally beside the graveyard, with headstones coming right up to the building. It almost seems like a teen exploitation film joke, a summer camp actually built across the lake from an insane asylum. Architecturally, the school is one of those early '60s Bauhaus-y structures of glass and cinder block. It's quite an attractive building, actually, and there's a friendliness, a sense of community about the place. It's in perfect repair. The floors gleam.
富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福高中旁边是一个巨大的墓地。真的是紧挨着墓地，墓碑一直延伸到大楼旁。这几乎看起来像青少年剥削电影的笑话，一个夏令营建在精神病院对面的湖边。在建筑学上，这所学校是60年代早期那种玻璃和煤渣块结构的包豪斯风格建筑。实际上，它是一栋非常漂亮的建筑，而且学校有一种友善的社区感。维修得很完美。地板闪闪发光。
We run into the school guidance counselors, who treat the Austrian Four like celebrities.
我们遇到了学校指导顾问，他们把奥地利四人组当作名人对待。
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
[侧面谈话]
I think I saw you on TV.
我想我在电视上见过你们。
You still learning how to write checks?
你们还在学习怎么写支票吗？
Despite the fact that she has two days to get the school ready for 4,000, and that Andrea, Lutz, Nikki, and Elke are by no means the only four new teachers starting this year, FDR's principal, the amazing Adele Vocel, takes the time to sit down with them in the conference room. She doesn't talk to them like Austrian teachers, just teachers. And it's not for my benefit, either. I am, in a word, tolerated.
尽管她还有两天时间让学校为4000名学生做好准备，而且安德里亚、卢茨、尼基和埃尔克绝不是今年新来的仅有的四名教师，但FDR的校长，了不起的阿黛尔·沃塞尔，还是抽出时间在会议室里与他们坐下来交谈。她不是把他们当作奥地利老师对待，而是仅仅当作老师。这也不是为了我，我是，一句话，被容忍而已。
As I said before, you chose a career that's probably the greatest career going. Don't be afraid of our kids. I don't know what you've heard of New York City kids. They're good kids. OK? But you've got the enthusiasm. You've got the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. You've got the conviction, or you wouldn't be here. So let everybody know. Let the kids know that's how you feel. OK?
正如我之前所说，你们选择了一个可能是世界上最伟大的职业。不要害怕我们的孩子。我不知道你们听说过纽约市的孩子们是什么样的。他们是好孩子。好吧？但你们有热情。你们有[听不清]。你们有信念，否则你们就不会在这里。所以让每个人都知道。让孩子们知道你们就是这么想的。好吧？
I follow along as Lutz and Andrea are shown the newly renovated science labs, introduced to the ninth grade biology curriculum, and meet Jim and Alex, two biology teachers who sit down with them and joke around like a Vaudeville duo for about 30 minutes or so. They're friendly and contagiously funny and irreverent, and like everyone we meet at the school, they project this sense of shared purpose and excitement. They make it look like great fun. And there's no false nobility here, either. There's none of that sunwashed earnestness of films like Dead Poets' Society. All of this is a long way towards dispelling the fear of the school year that begins in two days' time.
我跟着卢茨和安德里亚参观了新翻修的科学实验室，了解了九年级生物课程，并遇到了吉姆和亚历克斯，两名生物老师，他们坐下来和他们开玩笑，就像杂耍二人组一样大约谈了30分钟。他们友好、幽默且玩世不恭，像我们在学校遇到的每个人一样，他们展现了一种共同的目标感和兴奋感。他们让这一切看起来非常有趣。这里也没有虚伪的崇高感。没有像《死亡诗社》那样那种阳光洗过的认真感。所有这些都在很大程度上消除了对两天后开始的学年的恐惧。
I conjecture that a lot of the feeling of goodwill and helpfulness so evident at FDR seems to emanate in large part from Adele Vocel. She speaks to the Austrians, and indeed everyone we're introduced to that day-- from the vice principals to the payroll secretaries. As colleagues, not as subordinates.
我推测，在FDR显而易见的善意和帮助感，很大程度上似乎源于阿黛尔·沃塞尔。她与奥地利人交谈，事实上与我们那天介绍的每个人都交谈——从副校长到工资秘书。作为同事，而不是作为下属。
It strikes me that the New York these Austrians will be working in is very different from the New York inhabited by the members of the media covering them, including myself. For starters, there's a lack of ironic posturing to the Austrians, and to almost everyone I encounter on this story. No one is making constant air quotes or dropping their voices in "what, me, serious?" disaffection. No one acts like they've seen it before.
我突然想到，这些奥地利人工作的纽约，与覆盖他们的媒体成员（包括我自己在内）居住的纽约非常不同。首先，奥地利人几乎和我在这篇报道中遇到的每一个人都没有讽刺姿态。没有人不断地做引号手势，或者在表达怀疑时降低声音。没有人表现得好像他们以前见过这一切一样。
At one point during a teacher orientation, Adele Vocel read a poem called "Average" to a room full of adults. "I don't cause teachers trouble. My grades have been OK. I listen in my classes and I'm in school every day. My teachers say I'm average. My parents think so, too. I wish I didn't know that, because there's a lot I'd like to do. I'd like to build a rocket. I have a book to tell you how. And start a stamp collection. Oh, no use trying now. Because since I found on average, I'm just smart enough to see it means I'm nothing special, that I should expect to be."
在一次教师指导期间，阿黛尔·沃塞尔给一屋子的成年人读了一首名为《平均》的诗。“我不会给老师惹麻烦。我的成绩还可以。我在课堂上听讲，每天都在学校。老师说我平均。我的父母也这么认为。我希望我不知道这一点，因为有很多我想做的事。我想造一枚火箭。我有一本书教我怎么做。还想开始收集邮票。噢，现在试也没用。因为既然我发现平均意味着我没什么特别的，我就应该期待如此。”
Later on, at a reception at the Austrian consulate, another woman in public education planted herself in the middle of the room, took out a laminated card in your pocket, and read a poem to the effect of, a hundred years from now, it will not matter how much money I made, what kind of car I drove, how big my house was, whether or not I was famous. What will matter is that I made a difference in the life of a child.
后来，在奥地利领事馆的招待会上，另一位公共教育界的女性站在房间中间，掏出兜里的一张层压卡片，读了一首诗，大致意思是，一百年后，我赚了多少钱、开了什么车、房子有多大、是否出名都不重要了。重要的是我是否改变了一个孩子的生活。
Generally the words, I'm just going to redo this poem elicit feelings of mild embarrassment in people. How avid, how earnest. I'm not proud to admit that I was a little amused when I first heard these two problems. Neither of them is very good poetry, after all. But on reflection, I realize that they achieve precisely what poetry is meant to accomplish. They edify. They elevate. They speak to an underlying truth not immediately apparent. They change the way one looks at things.
一般来说，这些话，我只是要重读这首诗，会在人们心中引发轻微的尴尬感。多么狂热，多么认真。我并不为承认自己第一次听到这两个问题时感到有点好笑而自豪。毕竟，它们都不是什么好的诗。但反思一下，我意识到它们实现了诗歌本应达到的目标。它们启发。它们升华。它们触及了一种非直接显现的潜在真理。它们改变了一个人看待事物的方式。
We in the media have all been portraying the Austrians as heading off into a blackboard jungle. All cynicism, institutional neglect, and violence. When in fact, they're entering a world none of us reporters imagined. A world where being earnest and avid and passionate is anything but embarrassing.
我们媒体一直在把奥地利人描绘成正走向丛林。全是玩世不恭、制度疏忽和暴力。而实际上，他们正在进入一个我们记者从未想象过的世界。一个认真、狂热和充满激情的态度一点也不令人尴尬的世界。
It's been made clear to me by Adele Vocel that I am not welcome in the classrooms once the students arrive. He obligation, she tells me, is to the kids, and I would be an unnecessary distraction. I see the sense of this, but I need to see what happens with the Austrian four, so I invite them for dinner, and they accept, and seem happy to be asked.
阿黛尔·沃塞尔已经向我明确表示，一旦学生到来，我不欢迎进入教室。她告诉我，她的责任是学生，我会是一个不必要的干扰。我明白这一点，但我需要看看奥地利四人组会发生什么，所以我邀请他们吃晚饭，他们接受了，而且似乎很高兴被邀请。
We have two dinners together, one in September and one in March. At both, they describe the work as hard and time-consuming, with evenings spent either preparing lessons, grading homework, or marking the many, many tests they seem to administer-- far more than are given at schools in Austria. And seeing New York City teaching methods up close and firsthand, the Austrians are finding some of their own preconceptions debunked. They seem surprised and more than a little bit disappointed that their training turns out to be far more unconventional and modern than that of their American counterparts. It turns out they were being warned against "chalk and talk" at their orientation because "chalk and talk" remain such a tenacious mainstay of American teaching.
我们一起吃了两顿饭，一顿在九月，一顿在三月。在两顿饭中，他们都形容工作既困难又耗时，晚上要么准备课程，要么批改作业，要么标记他们似乎要进行的很多很多测试——远比奥地利学校要多。近距离亲眼观察纽约市的教学方法，奥地利人发现他们自己的一些先入之见被打破了。他们似乎很惊讶，而且有点失望，发现他们的训练结果比他们的美国同行要非传统和现代得多。事实证明，他们在指导时被警告不要使用“粉笔加讲课”，因为“粉笔加讲课”仍然是美国教学的顽固支柱。
You know, we were trying not to chalk and talk. And we were very eager to earn the American way of teaching, to see alternative concepts, alternative approach to teaching and all this stuff. And I think a lot of us have watched other teachers teaching, and gones that lessons, and all that we see is chalk and talk. You don't see anything else. And everyone was saying--
你知道，我们尽量不粉笔加讲课。我们非常渴望学习美国的教学方式，看看替代概念、替代教学方法等等。我想我们很多人观察过其他老师教书，参加过课程，看到的全是粉笔加讲课。你什么也看不到。每个人都在说——
[INAUDIBLE] doing group work or something is cool sometimes. No, we never did.
[听不清]做小组工作什么的有时候很酷。不，我们从来没做过。
I really dare to say that the Austrian teachers do more with the pupils than the American teachers. Really.
我真的敢说，奥地利老师和学生做的互动比美国老师多。真的。
And I think the American system is just [INAUDIBLE].
我觉得美国系统只是[听不清]。
Yeah, just blah blah blah blah blah. The kids are sitting there. They are bored.  And you think, ah ha, you know that maybe. And you could ask them and you see nobody knows it.
是的，只是吧啦吧啦吧啦。孩子们坐在那里。他们很无聊。你以为，啊哈，你知道也许吧。你可以问他们，你发现没人知道。
It's contrary to our beliefs, in a way. I think that everybody [UNINTELLIGIBLE] very disappointed about the American system. Very disappointed about it.
这在某种程度上与我们的信仰背道而驰。我觉得每个人[听不清]对美国系统感到非常失望。非常失望。
Take all that with a grain of salt. That was recorded in September. At the dinner in March, they feel calmer and have a more positive and three-dimensional view of American methods and school in general, as they themselves are more realistically viewed. After sharing three bottles of wine, I am given enough courage for my next question. The question that I have been waiting to ask since the day they entered the misbegotten California Lounge of Kennedy Airport
这些话姑且听之。那是九月录的。在三月的晚餐上，他们感觉平静多了，对美国方法和整个学校有了更积极、更立体的看法，因为他们自己也被更现实地看待了。在分享了三瓶葡萄酒后，我有了勇气问下一个问题。那个我从他们踏入肯尼迪机场不幸的加州休息区那天起就一直等着问的问题。
So now, have you guys ever seen The Sound of Music?
那么，你们看过《音乐之声》吗？
No.
不。
You don't know what it is?
你们不知道那是什么？
I have seen it in America.
我在美国看过。
Do you know what it is?
你知道那是什么吗？
Yeah.
知道。
No Austrian knows The Sound of Music.
没有奥地利人知道《音乐之声》。
Everybody tells me about it. They say, tell me how to sing "Edelweis."
每个人都跟我说起它。他们说，教我怎么唱《雪绒花》。
Hey! So you do know Sound of Music.
嘿！所以你们确实知道《音乐之声》。
We've been told about it.
别人告诉我们的。
By everybody.
每个人都这么说。
"But 'Edelweis,' that's the national anthem of Austria, isn't it?"
“但是《雪绒花》，那是奥地利的国歌，不是吗？”
Nobody knows "Edelweis"?
没人知道《雪绒花》？
No. It's not an Austrian folk song. It's nothing.
不。它不是奥地利民歌。什么都不是。
And we just thought, we just assumed that Maria von Trapp was a folk hero in Austria.
我们只是认为，我们只是假设玛利亚·冯·特拉普是奥地利的民间英雄。
No one knows her.
没人认识她。
You know who Julie Andrews is?
你知道朱莉·安德鲁斯是谁吗？
Yes. Mary Poppins. And Victor and Victoria.
知道。玛丽·波平斯。还有《雌雄莫辨》。
Ever the gracious host, and ever eager for a colorful setting to exploit in the service of this radio story, I take the Austrians to see the New York panorama at the Queens Museum in Flushing Meadows. It's an enormous diorama of the five boroughs with scale models of every single building in the greater metropolitan area. I checked. Everything is there, right down to a half-inch replica of the four story brownstone where I live.
作为一个永远亲切的主人，总是渴望利用多彩的环境来服务这篇广播报道，我带着奥地利人去法拉盛草原皇后区博物馆看纽约全景。这是一个巨大的立体模型，包含大都市区每一栋建筑的等比例模型。我核实过了。一切都在那里，一直到我住的那栋四层褐砂石建筑的半英寸复制品。
The diorama. is really big. Certainly a healthy percentage of a football field in size. Spectators walk around its perimeter on a catwalk from above.
这个立体模型非常大。至少有足球场大小的一个健康百分比。观众从上面的猫道绕着它的周边走。
The videotaped presentation about the display's construction that plays constantly on loop begins with an announcer exclaimed over a Gershwin score, "New York City, the Big Apple, making it big, the arts capital of the world." This bit of cheap New York, New York propagandist metaphor seems a little naive. Because what one actually sees by looking at this accurate depiction of the city in its entirety is that most of the city, the New York that is New York to most New Yorkers, is actually Queens, Brooklyn, Staten Island, the Bronx, which all contain some pretty vast areas of Urban blight and desolation.
那个关于展品建设的录像带在循环播放，开头是播音员对着格什温的配乐惊呼：“纽约市，大苹果，做大，世界艺术之都。”这种廉价的纽约宣传隐喻看起来有点天真。因为通过观察这个城市整体的精确描绘，一个人实际上看到的是，这个城市的大部分——对大多数纽约人来说是纽约的纽约——实际上是皇后区、布鲁克林、史坦顿岛、布朗克斯，它们都包含了一些相当广阔的城市荒芜区。
It is the perfect backdrop to ask them how they're doing. They are assimilating rapidly.
这是问他们过得怎么样的绝佳背景。他们正在迅速融入。
The relation to the kids gets better and better. And in some classes, it's really interesting now. You know all of them. How to handle the kids. I mean, it's possible not to make it more interesting for both sides.
与孩子的关系越来越好。在一些课堂上，现在真的很有趣。你知道他们所有人。如何处理孩子。我的意思是，让双方都觉得更有趣是可能的。
So now do they seem different from Austrian kids?
那么，他们看起来和奥地利孩子不同吗？
Yes. I mean, I don't think that in Austria the relationship could be that's-- how do you say?-- unformal.
是的。我的意思是，我不认为在奥地利那种关系能成为——怎么说呢——非正式的。
Informal.
非正式的。
Informal, yes, informal. Don't think so. Because they are making jokes, and I'm laughing, I'm making jokes, and they are laughing. It's very seldom you find that. I think so.
非正式的，是的，非正式的。不这么认为。因为他们在开玩笑，我在笑，我在开玩笑，他们在笑。你很少能发现这一点。我是这么认为的。
Do you feel like teachers or do you feel like foreign teachers?
你感觉像老师，还是像外国老师？
Now I feel like a teacher.
现在我感觉像个老师。
I still don't feel like a teacher.
我还是没感觉像个老师。
We're standing over the Brighton Beach and Rockaway is part of the diorama, Manhattan far behind us. And while it's certainly the most crowded of the islands, its buildings are the tallest, it's also noticeably smallest. Seeing it from here, from the equivalent of a few thousand feet up, Manhattan's disproportionate influence, the power of its few over the millions in the outer boroughs, seems not just strange. It seems futile.
我们站在布莱顿海滩和洛克威上方，它们是立体模型的一部分，曼哈顿在我们身后很远。虽然它当然是岛屿中最拥挤的，建筑最高，但它也明显最小。从这里看，从相当于几千英尺高空俯瞰，曼哈顿不成比例的影响力，它少数人对外部行政区数百万人掌握的权力，不仅看起来很奇怪。它看起来很徒劳。
All of us in the media have been wondering how the Austrians would deal with it all. Expecting them to crumble when actually faced with real New York. That the smug assurance that Manhattanites like myself know what real New York is. But more than almost anyone I know, these four teachers have been thrust into a uniquely diverse and mixed environment where almost everyone is from somewhere else.
我们媒体的所有人都一直在想奥地利人会如何应对这一切。期待当他们真正面对现实中的纽约时会崩溃。那种像我这样的曼哈顿人认为自己知道现实纽约是什么的自鸣得意。但比我认识的大多数人都要好，这四位老师被推入了一个独特多样和混合的环境中，几乎每个人都来自别处。
In my search for an authentic backdrop to this scene, I brought these teachers to a large simulacrum, when probably the most authentically New York place is the block they live on. It's time to find their houses.
在为这个场景寻找真实背景的过程中，我把这些老师带到了一个大型模拟体，而可能最真实的纽约地方就是他们居住的那条街。是时候找到他们的房子了。
There's a light.  A red light. Where are we? Here. OK. Now we look for [? Rockaway. ?]
有一盏灯。一盏红灯。我们在哪里？这里。好的。现在我们找[？洛克威？]。
OK. This Sunset Park?
好的。这是日落公园？
Which? The small green or the big green?
哪个？小的绿色还是大的绿色？
Big green is the Queens cemetery. And small one is the Sunset Park. Sunset Park. Fifth Avenue till Seventh Avenue.
大的绿色是皇后区公墓。小的是日落公园。日落公园。第五大道到第七大道。
Night descends upon the miniature city. Their city. The sky darkens and blacklights illuminate the buildings, whose windows seem that up in millions of pinpoints. A few moments later, it is morning again, and another day dawns on the greatest metropolis on earth. The orchestra on the video plays. It is all one can do not to stretch out one's arms and turn around like some singing nun on the mountainside for the sheer joy and beauty and hugeness of it all.
夜晚降临到这个微缩城市。他们的城市。天空变暗，黑光照亮了建筑，窗户似乎在数百万个光点中亮起。片刻之后，又是早晨，地球上最伟大的大都市迎来了新的一天。视频里的管弦乐队奏响了乐曲。一个人能做的就是不张开双臂像某个在山坡上唱歌的修女那样转圈，为了这一切纯粹的喜悦、美丽和庞大。
Tiny planes on invisible wires come in for landings and take off from the diorama airport. And far higher than all of them, an airplane sails through the sky, tracing its path from across the Atlantic westward to somewhere else on the continent. Nikki wonders aloud how any plane passing over New York could possibly resist landing there. Indeed, how could any aircraft ignore the very center of the universe? He's become a real New Yorker at last.
看不见电线上的小型飞机从立体模型机场降落和起飞。在它们所有人之上，一架飞机穿过天空，沿着它横跨大西洋向西飞往大陆上其他某个地方的路径。尼基大声想知道任何经过纽约的飞机怎么可能拒绝降落在那儿。确实，任何飞行器怎么能忽视宇宙的中心？他终于成了真正的纽约人。
David Rakoff lives in Manhattan, USA.
大卫·拉科夫住在曼哈顿，美国。
[MUSIC - "NEW YORK CITY" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - “纽约市” 巨人乐队]
Coming up, trying to convince Dad down in Florida that it was a good idea to immigrate to America all those years ago. That's in a minute on Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来，试图说服佛罗里达州的爸爸，当年移民到美国是一个好主意。请关注一分钟后的国际公共电台节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Welcome to America.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是“欢迎来到美国”。
So I'm on a plane coming home from oversees. And the plane lands and is taxiing to the gate. And the flight attendant gets on the PA and says all the usual things they say. The weather, the local time, customs information. And she ends by saying, we hope you enjoy your stay in the United States of America.
所以我正坐飞机从海外回家。飞机着陆并滑向登机口。空乘人员通过公共广播说了一些他们通常会说的话。天气、当地时间、海关信息。最后她说，我们希望您享受在美国的时光。
We hope you enjoy your stay in the United States of America. The thought had never occurred to me before. And then I thought, yes, I do hope I enjoy my stay in the United States of America. My, you know, 50, 60, 70, whatever it is year stay.
我们希望您享受在美国的时光。我以前从未想过这个念头。然后我想，是的，我确实希望我能享受在美国的时光。我的，你知道，50，60，70，无论多少年的时光。
Because you know, not everybody does. Though that's usually the story we tell ourselves as Americans. The story we tell ourselves about people coming to this country is that hopeful people coming here, escaping political oppression, escaping poverty. And it's hard at first for them to adjust, but then they do, because everybody has so much more here than they did back home where they came from. That is the story we usually tell ourselves about coming to America.
因为你知道，并不是每个人都能享受到。虽然那通常是我们作为美国人讲述的故事。我们对自己讲述关于人们来到这个国家的故事是，充满希望的人来到这里，逃避政治压迫，逃避贫困。起初他们适应起来很难，但后来他们做到了，因为每个人在这里拥有的都比他们在家乡多得多。这就是我们通常对自己讲述关于来到美国的故事。
I don't really think I like this place. Life is a little bit harder here. Very difficult than in Africa. It's very, very difficult.
我不认为我真的喜欢这个地方。在这里生活有点困难。比在非洲非常、非常困难。
Ignatius is here for school. Works in a parking garage. When he's done his studies, he wants to move back home to Cameroon, where he won't have to work from eight in the morning to one at night.
伊格内修斯是来这里上学的。在停车场工作。当他完成学业后，他想搬回喀麦隆的老家，在那里他不必从早上八点工作到凌晨一点。
In Africa, only if you work in a hospital, they should be working after six or seven PM. After five, most offices, every place is closed. In Africa, people are not fast-forward, fast lane, fast driving. It's a little bit slow. At times I used to think that time runs faster here.
在非洲，只有如果你在医院工作，他们才会在晚上六点或七点后工作。五点之后，大多数办公室、每个地方都关门了。在非洲，人们不是快节奏、快车道、快驾驶。节奏有点慢。有时我过去以为时间在这里跑得更快。
Some people take a long time to convince, to feel like they belong here. Alex came over when he was eight from a small town in Sicily back in 1958.
有些人需要很长时间才能说服自己，感觉自己属于这里。亚历克斯是1958年八岁时从西西里岛的一个小镇过来的。
I mean, we would do the pledge allegiance, you understand? And a lot of kids, I noticed, would assimilate. Like my brother, for instance, assimilated really fast. And that's the thing about the 40 years that it has taken me to really call myself an American now.
我的意思是，我们会宣誓效忠，你明白吗？我注意到很多孩子会同化。比如我兄弟，同化得很快。这就是这四十年来我真正称自己为美国人所需要的时间。
What's amazing about his history is just how American anybody would think he was. He spoke English, worked among non-Sicilians, married a non-Sicilian, lived like this for decades. And still, he did not believe that he belonged here.
关于他的历史令人惊奇的是，任何人都会认为他有多么美国化。他讲英语，在非西西里人中工作，娶了一个非西西里人，这样生活了几十年。然而，他仍然不相信自己属于这里。
There was always the hope of going back, and there was always the feeling that I am Sicilian.
总是有回去的希望，而且总有一种感觉我是西西里人。
Do you think there's anything that could've changed that would make you feel more American? I mean, you had a job, you'd learnt the language, you'd married somebody. Your children were Americans, born American citizens.
你认为有什么事能改变让你感觉更美国化吗？我的意思是，你有工作，你学了语言，你娶了人。你的孩子是美国人，出生就是美国公民。
Yeah. By this time, for instance, my father, my mother had become citizens. I refused to become a citizen.
是的。到这时，比如我父亲，我母亲已经成为公民了。我拒绝成为公民。
How come?
为什么？
Because I didn't feel this was my country.
因为我不觉得这是我的国家。
And was there something about America that felt too different from the way you felt about yourself?
关于美国有什么感觉和你对自己感觉太不一样了吗？
Yeah. There was a lot of things I couldn't understand.
是的。有很多东西我无法理解。
Like at that point, what would those things have been?
比如在那一点上，会是什么东西？
You know, I didn't feel connected to the ground I walked on. I didn't feel like I was sitting on the chair I was sitting on. When I was eating, I felt that I wasn't eating food.
你知道，我感觉不到与我脚下行走的土地有联系。我不觉得我正坐在我坐的椅子上。当我吃东西时，我觉得我没在吃东西。
What changed his feeling about America? When his mother was buried here, in American soil. When he found a church and the community here. When he spent time alone in the wilderness in southern Utah. He became a citizen in 1998, after 40 years.
什么改变了他对美国的感受？当他的母亲被埋葬在这里，在美国的土地上时。当他在这里找到了教堂和社区时。当他独自在犹他州南部荒野度过时光时。1998年，在40年后，他成了公民。
Some people never make the transition. And that is the subject of our next act in our program today. Act Two. Are Movies Stronger than Communism? This is the story of a father and son, told by the son, Juan Zaldivar, who was born in Cuba.
有些人永远无法完成这种转变。这就是我们今天节目下一幕的主题。第二幕。电影的力量比共产主义更强大吗？这是一个父亲和儿子的故事，由出生在古巴的儿子胡安·萨尔迪瓦讲述。
We never thought about leaving Cuba. At least, as a 13 year old, I never thought that I was going to leave Cuba. I knew that my uncles had left in the '60s. And I grew up in the system. I never thought that I was going to leave. My picture of the United States was, you know, this is a place full of monopolies and prostitution and drugs, and you couldn't go out in the street at night, because you'd get mugged.
我们从未想过离开古巴。至少作为一个13岁的孩子，我从未想过我会离开古巴。我知道我的叔叔们在60年代离开过。我在这个体系中长大。我从未想过我会离开。我对美国的看法是，你知道，这是一个充满垄断、卖淫和毒品的地方，你晚上不能走在街上，因为你会遭到抢劫。
Everything a good young communist is supposed to believe.
一个优秀的年轻共产主义者应该相信的一切。
Yeah. I basically believed everything that I was told.
是的。我基本上相信我被告知的一切。
When the Mariel boatlift happened in 1980, there were a few people went into the Peruvian embassy and asked for asylum. There was a big civil unrest was created by the fact that within a week, there were about 500 people crammed in the Peruvian embassy, asking for political asylum.
1980年马列尔偷渡事件发生时，有一些人进入秘鲁大使馆寻求庇护。一周内，大约有500人挤在秘鲁大使馆寻求政治庇护，造成了巨大的社会动荡。
And Fidel had a speech on national television, and claimed that anybody that wanted to leave, could, because anybody wanted to leave wasn't really wanted for the revolution, and was a parasite of the revolution. So he created demonstrations nationwide. I was actually out at those demonstrations, screaming against people that were leaving.
菲德尔在国家电视台上发表了演讲，声称任何想离开的人都可以离开，因为任何想离开的人都不是革命真正需要的，是革命的寄生虫。所以他在全国范围内制造了示威。我实际上就在那些示威中，大声反对那些离开的人。
And then within a week, my whole world turned around. Because one of my uncles who was in Miami came on a boat To pick us up.
然后在一周内，我的整个世界天翻地覆。因为我的一位在迈阿密的叔叔坐船来接我们。
You mean the family in Miami came back to retrieve you?
你是说迈阿密的家人回来接你们？
Yeah. Cubans who had left Cuba in the '60s who lived in Miami decided to go and get their families, because all of a sudden it was possible for them to leave the country.
是的。那些在60年代离开古巴、住在迈阿密的古巴人决定去把家人接走，因为突然之间他们可以离开这个国家了。
And so at some point about five years ago, you decide to make a movie about your family without any funding, and just shooting on your own to see what would happen.
所以大约五年前，你决定在没有任何资金的情况下拍一部关于你家人的电影，只是自己拍摄看看会发生什么。
Yeah. I started by basically just asking the whole family to tell me how they remember the whole experience.
是的。我开始基本上只是要求全家人告诉我他们是如何记住整个经历的。
My other objective when I first started shooting was to try to find out, you know, what had gone in the mind of my dad, and whether he felt OK with the decision that we had made about coming over. Because I felt that once we got here, even though our family was brought together in a sense, he also retracted from us. And I felt that he seemed more depressed and dejected, and he had a job that wasn't so great. And he was always afraid to lose it. He works a lot of hours. He doesn't get paid very well.
我第一次开始拍摄时，我的另一个目标是想弄清楚，你知道，我爸爸脑子里在想什么，他是否对自己做出的来这里的决定感到满意。因为我觉得一旦我们到了这里，尽管我们的家庭在某种意义上团聚了，但他却从我们身边退缩了。我觉得他看起来更加沮丧和颓废，他有一份工作并不怎么好。而且他总是害怕失去它。他工作很长时间。薪水不太高。
And so he wasn't like that when I was growing up. He was building a house in Cuba. He had friends that supported-- they found ways to get food and clothing. And he was a much more outgoing than he was once we got to Miami. So I wanted to find out what had happened.
所以在我成长过程中他不是这样的。他在古巴盖房子。他有支持他的朋友——他们找到了获取食物和衣服的方法。他在我们到达迈阿密之前要外向得多。所以我很想知道发生了什么。
And so I decided this summer to go back to Cuba and ask several questions. And one of them was, did we make the right decision? I wanted to see what my family that was left behind was like, and what their life was like. And I was hoping that in going back, I would find something that would make him feel better about the decision that we made.
所以今年夏天我决定回到古巴问几个问题。其中之一是，我们做出了正确的决定吗？我想看看被留下的家人怎么样，他们的生活是什么样。我希望通过回去，我能找到一些东西让他对我们做出的决定感到好受些。
So I took the trip. I went back in August of last year. And last summer was the first time I had been back in 18 years. And it was a very intense trip. Day-to-day life there is very, very hard. And it became very clear to me he had indeed made the right decision. That our lives and the opportunities that we have had here, we would have never had there.
所以我去了。去年八月我回去了。去年夏天是我18年来第一次回去。那是一次非常强烈的旅行。那里的日常生活非常、非常艰苦。我很清楚他确实做出了正确的决定。我们在那里永远不会拥有我们在这里拥有的生活和机会。
Why? What did you see? What kind of situation were your family members in?
为什么？你看到了什么？你的家人处境如何？
I talked to a lot of young people when I was there, and I saw that a lot of them had a lot of ambitions that they felt were never going to happen. They wanted either to study things that they were not allowed to study, because everything's rationed, so there's only a certain number of positions for lawyers every year, per town. A lot of them felt also, even if they could study what they want, they could never really get the things that young people have in, say, America or other parts of the world.
我在那里和很多年轻人谈过，我看到他们很多人都有很多雄心壮志，但他们觉得永远不会实现。他们要么想学习他们不被允许学习的东西，因为一切都是配给的，所以每个城镇每年只有一定数量的律师职位。他们很多人也觉得，即使他们能学习他们想要的，他们也永远无法真正获得比如在美国或世界其他地方年轻人拥有的东西。
And then what about your family members? Did they speak directly to your dad? You know, through the video camera?
那你的家人呢？他们直接对你爸爸说话了吗？你知道，通过摄像机？
Yeah. I collected a series of video letters when I was in Cuba. And I took some from family members. And then I also went and sought out friends of my father that I knew were very close to him before he left. And they wanted to see him again. They said not to be afraid to go back. That nothing was going to happen, that people go back all the time. And they said to him that if he were to come to Cuba without a shirt on his back, he would leave fully clothed and fully fed, and that they would make sure that would happen. And he was very emotional when I showed him the footage.
是的。我在古巴时收集了一系列视频信件。我从家人们那里拍了一些。然后我也去寻找了父亲的朋友，我知道在他离开之前他们和他非常亲近。他们想再见到他。他们说不要害怕回去。什么都不会发生，人们一直在回去。他们对他说，如果他赤身裸体来到古巴，他们会让他穿得整整齐齐、吃得饱饱的，他们会确保这一点。当我给他看视频时，他非常激动。
And what did they tell them about whether or not he should have left? Did they tell him that he should have stayed?
他们告诉他关于他是否应该离开了吗？他们告诉他他应该留下吗？
No. They told him that he shouldn't feel bad for the fact that he left. That they understand that it was probably the hardest decision he's ever made. They said, look, your family has done well. You should not feel bad about it. Here's your son, coming back to find his roots and make a connection with the people that he left behind. And they reassured him all of the things that I had been saying to him.
不。他们告诉他，他不应该因为离开了而感到难过。他们理解这可能是他做过的最艰难的决定。他们说，看，你的家人做得很好。你不应该为此感到难过。这是你的儿子，回来寻找他的根，与他留下的人建立联系。他们向他保证了我一直告诉他的一切。
And when you showed him the footage, what was his reaction? Was he reassured?
当你给他看视频时，他的反应是什么？他得到安慰了吗？
No. He still set that that's something that he's always going to feel, no matter what I can say to him.
没有。他仍然说无论我说什么，这都是他永远会有的感觉。
Do you think he regrets coming here and bringing you all here?
你认为他后悔来到这里并把你们都带到这里吗？
You know, I think because he was achieving things for himself right before he left, and he hasn't really been able to do that as much once he's been in the United States, part of him has to feel that his life was moving in a better direction when he was there. I guess I don't know. He hasn't said that he regrets having come to the United States.
你知道，我觉得因为他在离开前刚刚为自己取得了一些成就，而他自从在美国以来并没有真正做到那么多，他内心的一部分一定觉得他在那里时生活在向更好的方向发展。我猜我不知道。他没说他后悔来到美国。
But he is disappointed in how things have gone since he's been here.
但他对自从来到这里之后事情的发展感到失望。
I think so. I think he expected things to go better. I think he expected to achieve the American dream that everybody talks about. And he just doesn't like the way this culture works. He doesn't like that people have to have two jobs, and he doesn't like the fact that you don't get to see your relatives every day, and that people don't live close enough that you can go walk to somebody's house and borrow a cup of coffee.
我想是的。我想他期望事情会更好。我想他期望实现每个人都在谈论的美国梦。他只是不喜欢这种文化的工作方式。他不喜欢人们必须做两份工作，他不喜欢你不能每天见到亲戚，而且人们住得不够近，以至于你不能走去某人家里借杯咖啡。
So he feels very alienated. He feels he has to drive everywhere. Everybody works different hours, so he can't really see his brothers as often as he would like. He never sees his nieces and nephews.
所以他感到非常疏远。他觉得他必须到处开车。每个人工作时间不同，所以他不能像他希望的那样经常见到他的兄弟们。他从来看不到他的侄子和侄女。
It's interesting. He's disappointed in America, but it's in such a different way than the Communist government of Cuba told him what America would be. Like, if Fidel had been saying, you know, if you come to America, you'll be working two jobs, your family won't live down the block, might've had more of an effect.
这很有趣。他对美国感到失望，但与古巴共产主义政府告诉他的美国的样子非常不同。比如，如果菲德尔一直说，你知道，如果你来美国，你得打两份工，家人不会住在这个街区，可能会有更大的影响。
Yeah, perhaps. Don't give him any ideas.
是的，也许吧。别给他任何主意。
You guys have been here for almost two decades. Do you think at this point he feels American?
你们在这里已经快二十年了。你认为现在他感觉自己是美国人吗？
You know, he just became a citizen. And I talked to him about it. I was in New York and I wasn't able to go down-- I wanted to be there when he was going in for his swearing.
你知道，他刚刚成为公民。我和他谈过这件事。当时我在纽约，我没法下去——他去宣誓时我想在场。
And what made him decide to do it right now? Why now?
是什么让他决定现在就做？为什么是现在？
I think the main thing was this law that passed that said that if you weren't an American citizen and you retired, you would lose all your benefits after a while. Yeah. I don't think he would have done it otherwise. I don't think he really has any interest.
我认为最主要的是通过了这条法律，说如果你不是美国公民，当你退休时，过一段时间你就会失去所有福利。是的。我不认为他会另做打算。我不认为他真的有任何兴趣。
He still feels like a Cuban who happens to be here.
他仍然感觉自己是个恰巧在这里的古巴人。
Yeah.
是的。
Is he thinking about going back now?
他现在想回去吗？
No. I asked them if he wanted to go back. I asked him right at the beginning, when I started shooting four years ago, if he wanted to go back to Cuba. And he said no. And I asked him in August, after I came back from Cuba, whether or not he still felt the same way, and he said that he still wouldn't go back. There's nothing for him there anymore.
不。我问过他们他是否想回去。四年前我刚开始拍摄时，我就问过他是否想回古巴。他说不。八月份我从古巴回来后，我问他是否还有同样的感觉，他说他还是不会回去。那里对他来说已经没什么了。
You must have been been surprised, when he saw the video that you had shot, you must've been surprised that it didn't kind of turn him around.
当你看到你拍摄的视频时，你一定很惊讶，你一定很惊讶它没有让他回心转意。
I really was. I, now, was a little disappointed. I, however, haven't shown him an edited thing.
我真的很惊讶。我现在，有点失望。然而，我还没给他看剪辑好的版本。
This is the dream of any artist, however, if I could just say.
这毕竟是任何艺术家的梦想。
Yeah. Well, because we've got all these very disembodied conversations, you know? Which I think is how he sees it. I've been thinking about this and working, it's a whole process for me. So I have all these ideas that I've been mulling and I'm able to talk to you about them because I've been thinking about them for four years. I think with him, it's more like separate conversations that he's had with me. And he hasn't really been able to sit down and evaluate the whole experience.
是的。好吧，因为我们进行了所有这些非常脱节的对话，你知道吗？我认为他是这么看的。我一直在思考这个问题并工作，对我来说这是一个完整的过程。所以我有了所有这些想法，一直在咀嚼，我能和你谈论它们，因为我已经思考了四年。我想对他来说，这更像是我和他进行过的单独对话。他还没有真正能够坐下来评估整个经历。
Has your dad talk to you, has he noticed the level of energy that you're putting into healing this thing for him? Is your dad touched by what it is that you're trying to do? Does he understand--?
你爸爸跟你谈过吗，他注意到你为治愈这件事投入的精力了吗？你爸爸被你所做的事触动了吗？他理解吗——？
I don't think he understands fully. No matter how many times I say it, I don't think he sees it as something that I'm doing for him. I think actually that before the trip, all this time, he thought that I was doing it because somehow I questioned whether my decision to come was right or not. And I think that his brothers thought that too, because my uncle even mentioned it at one point. I don't know that he necessarily knows that this movie, it's about me trying to make them feel better about the decision.
我不认为他完全理解。不管我说多少次，我不认为他把它看作我为他做的事。事实上，我觉得在旅行之前，一直以来，他以为我这么做是因为某种程度上我质疑我做出决定是否正确。我觉得他兄弟们也这么想，因为我叔叔甚至在某个时刻提过。我不知道他是否一定知道这部电影是关于我试图让他们对所做的决定感觉好些。
It's just striking. I feel like what you're doing is that you're using the tools of rationality to achieve something which maybe can't be achieved, because it's just a feeling. Do you know what I mean? On his part. That feeling that he has isn't going to change through argumentation.
这太引人注目了。我觉得你正在做的是利用理性的工具去实现一些可能无法实现的事情，因为那仅仅是一种感觉。你知道我的意思吗？就他而言。他拥有的那种感觉不会通过争论而改变。
And now I feel like you've enlisted the full power of like, motion picture narrative, do you know what I mean? I imagine, like, OK, so you've gone down, and you have this whole story going, and you've shot these people, and you have these images. And at some point, they'll be music underneath the whole thing. You'll have all of these things. And the notion of, will it change this man's point of view about himself? It's just, I wonder if it can. If all the power can. You know, you think about, like, what is the power of a movie? And does it include the power to change a person's feeling about himself?
现在我觉得你已经动用了像电影叙事一样的全部力量，你知道我的意思吗？我想象，好吧，你下去了，你有整个故事在进行，你拍摄了这些人，你有这些画面。在某个时刻，整个事情下面会有音乐。你会有所有这些东西。关于电影的力量是否会改变这个男人对自己的看法？我只是想知道它是否能。如果所有的力量都能。你知道，你思考，电影的力量是什么？它是否包括改变一个人对自己感受的力量？
You know, sometimes, if somebody were to paint a picture of you, you may or may not think that it looks like you. But I think that if you stared at it for hours, you start seeing the way somebody else sees you. And there's no way you cannot learn something from that. Whether you think that it looks like you or not.
你知道，有时候，如果有人为你画了一幅画，你可能会也可能不会觉得它看起来像你。但我认为如果你盯着它看几个小时，你开始看到别人看你的方式。而且你不可能从中什么也学不到。无论你认为它看起来像不像你。
Him and I might never see eye-to-eye. He may never see my argument. He might never feel better about being here. But there's got to be something-- he must be able to learn something, from just seeing my perception of the whole thing. And I think it will give him more insight into how I perceive him as a human being, and get to know each other as two men, and not necessarily as a father and son.
我和他可能永远看不对眼。他可能永远看不到我的论点。他可能永远不会对来到这里感觉更好。但一定有什么——他一定能从仅仅看到我对整个事情的感知中学到一些东西。我想这会让他更深入地了解我如何将他视为一个人，并把我们当作两个男人而不是父子来彼此了解。
So even if it doesn't give him his own life, in a certain way, it gives him you.
所以即使它没有给他自己的生活，在某种程度上，它给了他你。
Yeah.
是的。
Juan Zaldivar's movie about his father in Cuba is called 90 Miles. 90 miles is the distance between the two countries, the US and Cuba. In the time since we first broadcast this weeks' radio show, he has finished his film. You can get more information about it at www.90miles.com.
胡安·萨尔迪瓦关于他父亲在古巴的电影叫做《90英里》。90英里是两国之间——美国和古巴——的距离。自我们首次播出本周广播节目以来，他已经完成了他的电影。您可以在 www.90miles.com 获取更多信息。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus. Engineering help from Mr. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Williams. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。工程帮助来自[听不清]威廉姆斯先生。伊丽莎白·迈斯特运营我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Or visit our website. You can get cassettes there. Or even better, you can hear our programs for free right there. www.thisamericanlife.org. That easy-to-remember name. www.thisamericanlife.org.
要购买本节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们芝加哥的WBEZ。312-832-3380。再次重复，312-832-3380。或访问我们的网站。您可以在那里获得磁带。或者更好的是，您可以免费收听我们的节目。www.thisamericanlife.org。那个容易记住的名字。www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. This American Life comes to you proudly from the city of Chicago, Richard M. Daley, mayor. Funding for our program is provided by the listeners of WBEZ Chicago.
《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。本节目由芝加哥市为您带来，市长理查德·M·戴利。我们节目的资金由WBEZ芝加哥的听众提供。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says this about anybody who dared to turn away to another radio station during our program.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他对任何胆敢在我们的节目中转台的人说了这样的话。
Anybody who wanted to leave wasn't really wanted for the revolution, and was a parasite of the revolution.
任何想离开的人都不是革命真正需要的，是革命的寄生虫。
I'm Ira Glass. I hope you enjoy your stay in the United States of America.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。我希望您享受在美国的时光。
PRI. Public Radio International.
国际公共电台。